do you think and this is the first of
many rounds for Vivian usual Tara and
also and do any of your other children
show any signs of becoming out of this
and the only reason we never have
intended and we still don't to put our
children in film and and and encourage
them to be actors I'm encourage them to
be happy and whatever they wish to be
but the the reason that we ended up
needing to put Vivian in the film is
because there it was a character when
it's when Aurora is five and she has to
as she said not see me as a demon and
and all little kids that came to visit
said crewmembers would bring their
children and they would see me and they
would be terrified they would cry or
they would freeze and and they they
could certainly couldn't do a scene with
me so I didn't it it actually was
genuinely out of necessity that it had
to be Vivian so we could have a good
scene but I don't I don't know it was a
it's not it's it's it's still funny to
us you know like anybody it's our little
girl so we see her and she's you know
she's just silly and sweet and the idea
that she's in a movie is still kind of
funny to her mom and dad